How do you decide if you gave the successful presentation?
Well, these criteria.
Before you ever give a presentation, decide on the purpose.
What is it that you want people to do differently, think differently, or feel differently?
One of those three items should be your purpose, your goal.
And if at the end of your presentation, people are doing, thinking and feeling...
...what you want them to do, think or feel, then that was a successful presentation.
A successful presentation is not measured by the applause, by the nods,...
...by the questions, by the great PowerPoint slides.
A successful presentation is about moving people in the direction that you want them to move.
If you want to be more successful in your presentations,...
...have a look at this site, read the articles and tips, and techniques.
And if you really wanna grow, work with a speech coach.
I can help you as the speech coach for executives.
I can help you deliver those important million - dollar presentations.